[Music]
foreign
so for the past three years the cheapest
and only display that Apple's made has
been the five thousand dollar Pro
display xdr which would cost an extra
thousand dollars on top just for the
matte finish and another thousand
dollars just for the stand so in this
new studio display got announced you
know it's a very apple design it's a 27
inch 5K screen surrounded by all these
little apple bells and whistles and with
the stand included for 1600 bucks a lot
of Apple Fans were understandably very
happy but then after the dust of the
announcement settled a lot of us found
ourselves asking wait a second
is this actually a good deal
so now I've been using this display for
about two weeks now and I have an answer
for you but I need you to understand how
I'm getting there so for most people who
are not interested and we're never going
to buy this screen anyway the is it
worth it conversation basically comes
down to the spec sheet and just
comparing it with other similar displays
it's like when you go to buy a house and
the appraisal just goes and looks at
square footage and the number of
bedrooms and bathrooms and materials
used and proximity that comes up with a
price based on what other houses with
the same sort of specs are going for so
this new studio display it's 27 inches
diagonally 5K resolution 600 nits
brightness it's a IPS LCD at 60 hertz
with P3 color it's got a webcam up top
it's got some speakers at the bottom
some USBC ports around the back and it's
1 600 so if I was an appraiser looking
for a comparable house I would be
looking at the LG ultrafine 5K that is
also a 27 inch 5K IPS LCD it's at 500
nits also at 60 hertz with P3 color a
webcam some speakers and some USBC ports
on the back that's 1 300 but it's also
five years old and while there are not
that many other 5K displays out there
there are a ton of 4K screens and one of
those would be the Dell Ultra sharp
u2720q that is also a 27 inch IPS LCD
panel with thinner bezels also at 60
hertz and also with P3 color and some
ports around the back super well
reviewed
589 so if you just go by the specs of
the panel it's actually pretty clear
that this display and the tech you're
getting for the price
is a bad deal but the second you're
actually considering buying a display
you realize this it's not just the
display specs of the panel that make or
break the experience it's all the stuff
that surrounds the screen for someone
actually considering using it and Apple
products they just have a habit of doing
this thing where they don't have the
best specs on paper but they offer a
unique combination of things that make
it really hard to do any sort of
one-to-one comparison because nobody
else has that exact unique combination
of things like you know how they make up
the most cherry-picked stats in NBA
media like oh this guy just became the
third player ever to get a triple double
before his 26th birthday after eating
Apple Jacks for breakfast that morning
or like wow there's only five players to
play 800 games and join the 13.5
5.9
1.4 49 30 Club
anyway that's how it feels talking about
this monitor so first of all it's 5K not
4K and like I said there's tons of 4K
monitors out there but this one is 5K
for a reason it's basically the same
panel from the 27 inch iMac which many
people including myself really liked
even though it's quite old so it's
sitting at a solid 218 pixels per inch
and it also benefits from being exactly
twice the vertical and horizontal
resolution of 2560 by 1440. so scaling
is super clean and everything looks
sharper as a result and then as far as
single backlight LCDs go it's pretty
solid it's got bumped up to 600 nits
which is plenty fine indoors as long as
they're not near any windows I have not
had any issues worse than normal with
ghosting or light bleed as you see with
some LCDs but obviously it's nowhere
near something like a mini LED display
with separate backlight zones that can
do really good HDR and then this one
I've been testing is the Nano texture
version which is a 300 dollar upgrade
it's extremely good at killing
Reflections and it's impressive that
it's this good for 300 bucks when the
same treatment on the pro display was a
thousand bucks but honestly I still
probably wouldn't recommend it unless
you literally work with a window like
right behind you or something because
the version without Nano texture is
always going to be slightly sharper and
punchier and much easier to clean but
speaking of upgrades this monitor which
has the stand permanently attached so
you know it's included which is nice but
uh it has height adjustment
which is cool right it's nice but the
the base version doesn't have that and
so this just just the ability to adjust
height
is a 400 upgrade to this stand so the
version without high adjustment is a
little bit low and I think a lot of
people started to notice that and you
know the IMAX didn't have height
adjustment but just for a monitor this
expensive to have to spend 400 extra
dollars to be able to do this
seems kind of ridiculous even though you
can go to an Apple store if you do get
buyer's remorse and have them add it
after the fact but hey if you do it's a
really solid stand all metal perfectly
balanced and spring-loaded to hold the
panel firmly in place it's actually more
sturdy in my experience than the pro
display xdrs mostly because it doesn't
have to rotate and just the overall
build quality of this monitor is top of
the line it is built so well and of
course this will never show up on the
spec sheet and this isn't even something
traditionally that matters all that much
with a monitor something you don't touch
you know a phone you want to be built
well things you hold and carry but this
is just going to sit on your desk but
they went over the top with the build
quality the overall design aesthetic so
in a world of basically all plastic
monitors this one's Full Metal Jacket
sharp Corners the Precision drilled
perforations at the top for ventilation
all of it kind of is in a class of its
own and I love it they left enough room
inside for a power supply to be built in
so there's no power brick or wall wart
this is probably the best looking and
Best Built monitor out right now now of
course yes you'd have to really care
about something like that to spend extra
on it if it's just going to sit on your
desk but there also is a catch and it's
a really weird weird decision but the
power cable
is not removable I mean when you look
back here it's a black plastic Circle
that looks like it should be removable
and it turns out if you pull really hard
you can actually rip it out the back but
it's pretty clear it's not designed to
be removed by the user this is from the
same company that designed a new magsafe
connector for the new iMac this is a
super baffling Choice turns out there's
a special tool required to remove the
studio display properly I don't count
that as user removable we've all seen
what a normal removable monitor cable
looks like but now instead it's kind of
in this homepod situation where like
it's clearly not meant to be user
removed and so now if the cable does get
damaged at all if you run a wheel over
it or a pet shoes on it or something you
have to send the whole thing back to get
repaired
thumbs down now Above This panel is a 12
megapixel Ultra wide camera with center
stage and triple microphones all powered
by a literal a13 bionic chip for those
who remember correctly that's the same
chip that powered the entire iPhone 11.
now while this is basically the same
webcam Hardware as the new iPad Air it
looks substantially worse like it's just
flat and grainy all the time in any
lighting I throw at it maybe I just got
my hopes up too high I mean I knew it
would be softer because it's cropping
into a 12 megapixel Ultra wide frame so
there's less pixels a new wouldn't have
shallow depth of field or anything it's
not a big sensor but
I mean the mic sound pretty good as you
can hear but it there's just no Shadows
it refuses to let anything dark actually
look dark which for me is
not great apple is actually promising a
software update that may help things
imagine that a software update for a
monitor apparently it has 64 gigs of
onboard storage for some reason but yeah
bottom line is it's it's convenient that
there's a webcam built in but there's
definitely still a market for like an
opal C1 type webcam the stuff that looks
way better than this but then there are
the speakers so they're all situated in
the bottom of the monitor here there are
six total for Force canceling woofers
and two tweeters they say it's the best
computer speakers they've ever shipped
in any of their systems and it's true
it's 100 true this thing I've compared
it to the 16-inch MacBook Pro these are
substantially louder they fill a room if
you wanted to they can create a somewhat
convincing Dolby Atmos surround setup if
you want it's it's really good so for
built-ins they are above and beyond the
rest they don't sound as good as
dedicated speakers but if you really
want good built-in speakers then
yeah if you're into that please do it by
the way Apple should just make speakers
right I mean the homepod doesn't count
they should
right they should just make speakers so
anyway if you want a monitor for the
panel quality and the panel quality
alone
then there are lots of others just like
this for way less money but if you're
one of the surprisingly large group of
people who are waiting for a monitor
that would work really well in this
apple ecosystem World Of Products then
this is just what you've been waiting
for it's pretty much made to be used
with the new Mac Studio hence the name I
also plugged into the MacBook Pro which
charges the laptop at 96 Watts but
hilariously I really just didn't think
it was that great of a pair I mean it
looks great next to it but the MacBook
Pro has a much brighter higher refresh
rate mini LED display that just looks
way better to me and was preferable for
me to use so I just ended up wanting to
use the promotion of the laptop screen
all the time but then you know just for
fun you can plug it into an iPad and it
works perfectly normally mirrors and
charges the iPad and we also plugged
into a PC and it worked like a normal
monitor at full 5K resolution and it
does actually use the speakers and the
webcam but without any of the processing
or or Center Stage that comes from
lighting up that a13 what an odd
combination of parts for real honestly
for nearly two thousand dollars if you
just close your eyes and say okay it's
2022 and apple is going to make a studio
display
you'd expect
mini LED maybe or maybe promotion or
maybe it might have face ID or a good
webcam or just any combination of those
things instead it has none and a
non-removable power cable and a non-user
upgradable stand
Todd that is a rare swing and a miss for
me someone who works in a studio but the
real question the real question is is
the studio display a good deal or not
well
is the Rolls-Royce Ghost
a good deal because it's the only
four-door sedan with suicide doors and a
6.7 liter V12
for under four hundred thousand dollars
does that make it a good deal or how
about are the Nike hyperadapts a good
deal because they are the cheapest best
self-lacing shoes you can get right now
for 350 dollars does that make them a
good deal I guess what I'm trying to say
is maybe it doesn't really matter if
it's a good deal or not if it's exactly
what you want like if there are other
cheaper options it doesn't really matter
because there's only one that does the
exact thing that you want it to
and so that's what this is for some
people you're probably just going to
want to get this one
but yeah no it's not a good deal
[Music]